jeder merkt ist die energiekosten
explodieren insbesondere der strom ist
so teuer wie nie spätestens jetzt
wachsen die zweifel ob es wirklich
richtig war bis ende 2022 aus der
kernenergie auszusteigen
viele fordern mittlerweile offener
zumindest die verbleibenden akw es
vorerst weiter am netz zu lassen
millionen deutsche können ihn kaum noch
bezahlen firmen gehen pleite familien
sitzen im dunkeln die energiekosten
explodieren
der strom ist so teuer wie nie zuvor
putins angriffskrieg auf die ukraine das
embargo auf russisches öl und gas nur
zwei gründe für das drohende fiasko
deutsche energiepolitik ein fiasko der
abhängigkeit eine abhängigkeit
deutschlands geschaffen durch einen
jahrelangen kuschelkurs mit putins
russland ein kuschelkurs der nun an
unser aller geldbeutel geht die
ambitionierte energiewende in
deutschland hin zu grünem strom sie
kommt deutschland in dieser politischen
ausnahme situation besonders teuer zu
stehen klar ist der klimawandel betrifft
bedroht uns alle es muss gehandelt
werden doch der ausbau der erneuerbaren
energie ist noch lange nicht weit genug
fortgeschritten
ausgerechnet jetzt sollen die letzten
atomkraftwerke vom netz genommen werden
csu chef markus söder forderte bereits
im märz den ausstieg aus der kernenergie
zu überdenken
natürlich wäre eine verlängerung rein
technisch möglich es ist die frage ob
man es politisch will aber ich glaube so
für drei bis fünf jahre wäre das einfach
in dieser notsituation ein guter
übergang um billigen strom zu
produzieren der gleichzeitig auch keine
klimabelastung bringt
während die europäischen nachbarn
weiterhin voll auf die kernenergie
setzen und die eu diese erst vor kurzem
als grüne energiequelle einstuft konnte
der deutschen politik der ausstieg aus
der kernenergie scheinbar nicht schnell
genug gehen dabei ist atomstrom nicht
nur günstiger sondern auch sicherer und
entgegen jeglicher klimapolitischer
vernunft setzen jetzt ausgerechnet die
grünen voll und ganz auf kohle
ausgerechnet kohle die knapp 400 mal
schädlicher für die umwelt ist als
atomkraft in bild mahnt die csu
umweltexperten anja weisgerber auch
deswegen die grünen jetzt über ihren
schatten zu springen und neben dem
ausbau der erneuerbaren dem
vorübergehenden weiterbetrieb der
kernkraftwerke als brücke zuzustimmen
dass ausgerechnet grüne minister länger
auf kohlekraftwerke setzen entbehrt
jeglicher klimapolitischer vernunft am
endgültigen ausstieg aus der kernenergie
ändert unser vorschlag nichts während
uns die abhängigkeit von russischem gas
derzeit teuer zu stehen kommt schaffen
wir mit der unkoordinierten energiewende
und dem vorgezogenen atomausstieg gleich
die nächste abhängigkeit denn auch in
zukunft werden wir auf den strom anderer
länder angewiesen sein zu groß ist der
energiebedarf in deutschland
und während hier bei uns der teure und
aufwändig aus erneuerbaren energien
gewonnen strom nicht ausreichen wird
werden wir wahrscheinlich den billig
produzierten atomstrom aus unseren
nachbarländern dazu kaufen auch das wird
uns einiges kosten
[Musik]
wenn wirtschaftsminister habeck ist in
israel und im fokus der reise steht die
frage der energieversorgung israel hat
zwar gas kann deutschland aber nicht
einfach so kurzfristig aushelfen die
förderkapazitäten und die infrastruktur
sind darauf nicht ausgelegt doch man
arbeitet gemeinsam an lösungen sagt der
wirtschaftsminister
ich habe deutlich gemacht dass
deutschland und europa jetzt erdgas
brauchen und ich denke dass israel
darüber nachdenkt wie gas route zu
nutzen die es jetzt hat und das gas nach
ägypten zu bringen und es darüber nach
europa zu transportieren was natürlich
ein schönes symbol für die
zusammenarbeit zwischen israel und
ägypten im energiebereich und für die
zukunft wäre vielleicht mit erneuerbaren
energien
hkw verlängerung wurde im februar in
halbwegs haus geprüft doch seitdem hat
er das wort nie wieder in den mund
genommen uns jetzt zugeschaltet ist bild
reporterin nadja aswad live aus
jerusalem sie begleitet den minister
nadia in deutschland wird wieder über
atomkraft diskutiert und warum die
laufzeiten verlängert werden sollen und
nun dass der vizekanzler
lagarde in nahost da geht es auch um
energie will habeck denn die versorgung
sicherstellen
guten morgen patricia ja tatsächlich
sind hier die erneuerbaren energien im
fokus vizekanzler habe ich war ja schon
ende märz in katar und hat ein abkommen
zur lieferung von flüssiggas geschlossen
ich wollte aber nicht sagen um welche
menge es geht man spricht auch in israel
über das flüssiggas feld dass ich hier
befindet das aber noch nicht erschlossen
ist deswegen geht man auch eher davon
aus dass das nicht für deutschland
infrage kommen wird weil wir brauchen
kurzfristig energie
robert habeck hat deutlich gemacht dass
es hier darum geht die sonne zu nutzen
die vorhandenen energien zu nutzen und
daraus strom zu gewinnen der eventuell
auch deutschland zugute kommen könnte es
sind natürlich viele deutsche firmen in
der lage sofort zu helfen die notwendige
technik bereitzustellen und das ist das
was im fokus der reise steht also man
guckt wie kann man auf erneuerbare
energien setzen und was kann man was
kann man tun um in dem punkt die
energieversorgung sicherzustellen
tatsächlich war der vizekanzler gerade
hier bei mir auf der terrasse und habt
auch ein wort gesagt zu markus söder
nämlich hat er gesagt dass bayern
schlägt das problem hat das dort nicht
genug erneuerbare ausgebaut hätte und
damit hat er leider recht weil wenn wir
auf bayern schauen dann sehen wir da
wird schon extrem viel strom erzeugt aus
erneuerbaren energien obwohl die csu
gegen windkraft ist oder zumindest das
sehr sehr stockt
rechnet man aber diese stromerzeugung
hoch und guckt sich den stromverbrauch
bayerns an dann reicht das beileibe
nicht um den stromverbrauch zu decken
insofern ist klar warum habeck darin
oppositionsführer steht und das thema
was hier ganz klar im fokus ist sind
erneuerbare energie
der auftakt der reise war gestern aber
auch heute steht noch einiges auf dem
plan termine und treffen was genau steht
da heute auf der agenda in israel
heute ist tatsächlich ein eher ernster
morgen der vizekanzler wird gleich die
holocaust gedenkstätte jad vaschem
besuchen dass du dir zum zweiten mal da
war er zuletzt vor zwei jahren noch in
seiner funktion als parteichef jetzt
eben zum ersten mal in seiner funktion
als vizekanzler und wirtschaftsminister
im anschluss geht es für uns weiter in
die palästinensischen gebiete nach
ramallah und dann weiter nach jordanien
wo eben morgen eine große klimakonferenz
stattfindet die jetzt zum ersten mal
seit 2015 stattfindet und auch da stehen
die erneuerbaren energien im fokus und
robert habeck ist er zuversichtlich dass
dort wichtige punkte erreicht werden
können nadja aswad und live zugeschaltet
aus jerusalem vielen herzlichen dank für
deine informationen der gerne